Hey youtubers it's Charlie and the BBC just
released a new teaser trailer for Series 8.
The main reason was to confirm the premiere
date of August 23 which was pretty much when
I thought it would be. But even though it
was a super short clip we got loads of new
information so this is going to be a breakdown
of that.
Hello to all the new people, if you're just
finding me for the first time Doctor Who is
coming soon and I'm doing weekly bonus videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything. Whenever
episode 1 premieres I'm going to start a weekly
giveaway. It will work just like my Game of
Thrones giveaway and the Legend of Korra one
I'm doing right now.
So important stuff, like I said Doctor Who
Series 8 Episode 1 will air Saturday August
23rd on BBC one and BBC America. I don't know
all the channels it airs on internationally,
but if you've watched Doctor Who on television
in the past, it will be on that same channel
at the time it normally airs every week.
It wasn't super hard to guess that's when
the premiere was, it's the first Saturday
after the last day of their World Tour. If
any of you guys actually go to the World Tour
dates be sure to take pictures and let everybody
know in the comments. If they're coming to
a city near you it's worth it to try and go.
I live in California, so I won't make it to
the one in New York City but that's okay.
So let's break down the new trailer.
The first thing we notice is the huge change
to the Stalk of the TARDIS Console. It's red,
a very ominous red. The TARDIS interior itself
doesn't look too different which is expected
since they spent about 2 Million Dollars building
Matt Smith a new TARDIS for the 2012 Christmas
Special, the Snowmen.
I'd say that companions getting to travel
in multiple different TARDIS's was a rare
thing, but given all the changes in Doctors
since the 2005 reboot it seems like the final
companion any given Doctor travels with, has
a pretty good chance of traveling with the
next Doctor in their new TARDIS.
It's hard to argue if Capaldi's TARDIS is
new, because if they're just changing the
Stalk of the Console, it's a big change, but
not super huge. Until we get a better look
at the interior I'm going to call it a minor
revision. But not full on new.
I predict that there are also a few subtle
changes to the interior skin. But the superstructure
and the Gallifreyan symbols will stay the
same.
The explosions we've seen before, they're
just a continuation of the explosions that
started when Matt Smith regenerated into Capaldi
in the Christmas Special. The TARDIS always
seems like it crashes during a regeneration.
Whenever Tennant regenerated into Matt Smith,
he still new how to fly it. But it was severly
damaged which is one of the reasons he didn't
come back for Amelia Pond at the right time.
I have another theory about that though, since
the TARDIS has an awareness that seems a little
sharper than the Doctor's, I'm guessing it
took Matt Smith to adult Amelia Pond on purpose,
not because it malfunctioned.
Like we heard IDRIS say in The Doctor's Wife,
"I may not always take you where you want
to go, but I do always take you where you
need to go." I love how that implied that
The Doctor has absolutely no idea what he
needs to do. He just makes it up as he goes
along.
Maybe that was Moffat making fun of himself.
The voice over Capaldi has as it zooms into
his eye is a little sinister. "Clara Be My
Pal and tell me, Am I A Good Man?" the delivery
on that makes it sound like he's asking as
if he's not sure he WANTS to be a good man.
There was this April fool's joke that BBC
or someone did where they were disseminating
information that Peter Capaldi was in fact
the Master disguised as The Doctor, which
is ridiculous because we saw Matt Smith become
Capaldi.
But Moffat has already revealed that Capaldi's
Doctor will be much less accommodating, "Stern"
was the word used specifically, but I think
it just implies that he won't be as inclined
to help others as he was in the past.
If that's the case, the responsibility of
convincing him to help people week to week
is going to fall on Clara and the other companions
that will join up. If you haven't seen any
of my other videos for Series 8, I explain
who they are. It's basically the Danny Pink
character and his Sister. So somewhere after
Episode 4, there will be three companions
traveling in the TARDIS
Clara's line in the trailer, "I don't think
I know who The Doctor is anymore" is from
a different scene, she's not answering Capaldi's
question about being a good man. It's probably
from that first episode which means she might
be talking to Madam Vastra. We've seen pictures
of her on set for that first episode.
It stands to reason that The Doctor's friends
would be confused by Capaldi's behavior post-regeneration,
especially if he doesn't care about them like
he used to.
When the camera zooms in on Clara inside his
eyeball we just see his iris and pupil but
part of me wants to think the imagery is also
supposed to be a visual reference to either
a black hole or the Time Vortex that we see
in the opening credits, the untempered schism,
which we haven't seen since End of Time or
even the Eye of Harmony. There are a lot of
eyeball references in Doctor Who.
And the last thing which you may have missed
unless you watched the teaser a few times
was Capaldi's modified intro music. Steven
Moffat updated the opening credits music a
few times while he's been showrunner. Not
huge changes, just really small subtle ones.
Remember during the 50th Anniversary, they
played the original intro music, it's changed
a lot since that first broadcast, but the
basic structure and notes are still the same.
So expect a minor update for Capaldi's intro.
That's really the big thing that they haven't
shown off yet, Capaldi's official opening
credits scene. There have been a lot of fan
versions, but I'm wondering if they'll show
it off at Comic Con next month. They might
just wait till that first episode to reveal
it.
Sometimes when they take footage to Comic
Con it's just a super short highlight reel.
Last year they showed off what was basically
the first teaser for the 50th Anniversary.
So it's not a huge deal if you aren't in Hall
H. There's nothing they'll show in there that
you won't also see at the end of August, so
no worries.
But let me know, what do you think the Red
TARDIS Console means and do you think there's
some hidden imagery in that shot of his eye
at the end?
Because there's a ton of other videos I have
to do this weekend I'm not going to make a
Q&A video for this, so just ask all your questions
in the comments here and I'll try to answer
as many as possible.
Saturday is basically my new Doctor Who day.
Here's what my bonus videos are going to look
like till episode 1 premieres. It will be
1 video every Saturday, not including Comic
Con weekend. There will be some extra stuff
then. The week episode 1 airs I'll do a Saturday
Morning Bonus video, then an episode review
Saturday Night and a Q&A on Sundays. One for
each new episode. So that's like 36 plus Doctor
Who videos during the season.
I'm also going to do some special stuff for
the Christmas Special too just like Last Year,
but that's so far off I'm going to wait to
talk about it when we get closer.
In the meantime, be sure to subscribe to get
everything and click here to learn all about
the series 8 episodes and click here to learn
about the TOP 10 new companions I'd like to
see on Doctor Who.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!